the intrepid the Peripatetic Pat Forde
Pat forty yahoo sports national college
football basketball columnist if there's
a scandal you'll find pat forty outside
your door he joins us good morning no no
I don't want to see you outside my door
three rule changes that could help save
college basketball you're covering this
scandal the FBI investigation so I give
you the floor all right you know yeah I
think that just judging by what Mark
Emmert had to say Saturday I think that
there is a an acknowledgement now of a
broken system failed ability to police
the system and they're gonna have to do
some things differently and I think one
of the things that certainly he sounded
open to his letting players have agents
while they're in college and you know
they it's been done in hockey it's been
done in baseball so maybe it's time to
look at doing that in basketball and
probably in football as well beyond that
I think there's gonna be a strong push
to get the NBA on board with eradicating
the one-and-done rule and letting
players go pro out of high school or
having them do a similar baseball sort
of thing where they they if they come to
school they're gonna stay in school for
two or three years thirdly I think this
would be a tougher sell probably with
the college sports membership it's
something that should be considered is
name image likeness and or endorsements
similar to the Olympic model let players
be able to you know make an appearance
and get some money for that to have a
sponsor that sort of thing I think that
would be the toughest sell but I think
it's something else that should be
considered just to simply avoid the
charade that's we're uncovering here in
the last few months where is this story
right now it's still actually I think
fairly much in the in the incubation
stages you know there's so much more to
know we view documents from one guy who
works at one agency and it's a pretty
narrow swath of time for that guy and
there's 20 schools and 25 players
least implicated and a whole bunch of
middlemen and sneaker people and
financial advisors and so if the scope
of it is you know infinitely bigger than
that you know others involve other
agencies other shoe companies etc etc
how big can this thing go the question
is you know what's the feds appetite
yeah do they want to try to find all of
it or do they want to find enough that
they make a point and you know arrests
it right now for people but if they're
ten people if it turns out to be twenty
thirty forty where does it have what's
their appetite what kind of impact do
you think it has on this March Madness
well certainly cast a cloud on it but I
don't know whether it'll be anything
tangible on the court other than Texas
has withheld one of its players Eric
Davis San Diego State has withheld one
of his there's malik pope but those two
teams may not make the tournament in
terms of you know is Wendell Carter who
was named in the documents going to play
it appears so is Kevin Knox from
Kentucky going play it appears so
diandra Aten it appears he's going to
play at this point and things could
change but I think other than people
talking about it and coaches and players
having to answer questions about it I
think the show will go on pretty much as
advertised Aten plays against Oregon
Sean Miller does in coach what's that
say about both of this situation well
it's interesting I you know I think that
the fact that Aten played was
significant certainly the fact that
Miller did not coach is also significant
you know I think his situation is very
fluid and is kind of going to be a
prized day-to-day here you know they
play again obviously this week you know
Aten playing tells me that there's
nothing that the school has tangible
that says you definitively accepted
anything you know it's not all
completely cut and dried I don't think
but but they feel comfortable at least
putting him out there they vetted him
you know they know what this goes back
to September they've they've interviewed
him the FBI's interviewed him they've
been a lot of homework done on DeAndre
so I kind of expect to see him continue
to play have you heard the wiretap where
Sean Miller is alleged to be offering
the hundred thousand dollars
[Music]
I've heard no wiretaps will that be
available don't know no I I have no idea
you know what how did we find out about
the wiretap in the first place that was
ESPN reporting so I'm not sure what the
the methodology was there what went into
that story
we reviewed documents is what we did
here's my concern with all of this Pat
is that we our attention span is so
small that that that that feels like
it's really important now I don't know
how important it's going to be and I
don't know in a week from now with
conference tournament play then March
Madness you got NFL stuff with the
combine
you got Major League Baseball it's
important today I don't know how
important it is tomorrow
and then we move on to another story
deep fear that I mean we have a very
short attention span and there's nine
million things competing for our
attention you know and so it's easy for
things to come in one ear and be out the
other and in a couple of days as you
said somebody's gonna hit a buzzer
beater in a Big Ten game and we're gonna
be talking about that as you say oh this
is fun look how great this game is blah
blah blah blah blah next week it's gonna
be more with the conference tournaments
yeah there's there's so much else going
on and this is complicated slow stuff
you know do people want to stick with ya
story that it's complicated and slow
developing maybe not but I am quite sure
the story's not going away
it may just tell dormant for a while and
then things pop back up at later points
but I liken this to what happened with
baseball the Commissioner tried forever
to get drug testing and you know bring
these guys in and then all of a sudden
Congress got involved in it and then we
saw movement there progress there and
people held accountable the n-c-double-a
is said well yeah we were aware of this
and we've heard stories about it but
they're toothless the FBI comes in now
all of a sudden game on
can you see a parallel here between
those two sure yeah I think it's the
best thing that could have happened is
that this became a legal matter and you
can you can quibble over the legality
and
this is what the FBI should be doing
with its time but if you're a college
sports fan and you want to know what's
really happening out there this is
what's really happening and this is how
it took the FBI and it took the Southern
District of New York Attorney's Office
to get to this stuff so sometimes I
think the NCAA is so hamstrung by its
membership and by itself that it needs
you you need somebody else to come in
and shake up the shake up the works and
kind of get things moving and I think
that's the possibility that we're at a
stage where something like this when you
can throw down documents and at least
suggest this isn't proving but suggests
okay there's tens of thousands of
dollars going to a lot of different guys
out there maybe we need to change some
things up you know what I'm smelling
right now what's that a sequel to blue
chips what do you think get your agent
on it absolutely yeah all right just
throwing it out there
you know what if there's a role for a
reporter then I might cast you as that
reporter I will if not then maybe Andy
Katz gets the role I don't know or Jeff
good my night so I don't know Pat I mean
I'm but I'll hold out hope for it all
right
Pitino I could use Pitino Pitino as an
extra I can have him as a coach he's got
time Thank You Pat we appreciate your
time all right thank you that's the
national college football basketball
columnist from Yahoo Sports
our good friend Pat 44 more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
at
[Music]